you know this band
government mule i know the span
government you know absolutely oh yeah
they're good hero oh my god i know
amazing did i ever tell you the story
about warren haynes and my mother
no and by the way we should mention that
warren haynes used to play with the
allman brothers but okay that's right
okay so on september 11th my mother i
grew up outside of washington dc and so
my house is maybe about eight miles from
the pentagon i was in los angeles when
it happened and so uh i called my mother
to check in to make sure she was okay
because the pentagon which also got hit
was close to my house
and she said oh there's sirens
everywhere and the streets are closed
down and i said you got to get out of
there you got to get out of there she
goes i don't know where to go i said let
me figure it out so i called my
management and i said hey are there any
tour buses around i want to get my mom
out to los angeles i got to get her out
of virginia and they said let's check
and about three hours later they called
they said okay there's a tour bus and
they can pick her up in three hours but
there's a catch she has to share it with
warren haynes from government mule and
the almond brothers
and i said okay and i knew him he's the
sweetest man in the world he's amazing
so i called my mom and i'm like mom i
got you a bus start packing but listen
you got to share it with this dude from
the allman brothers and i said i promise
he's the sweetest guy in the world and
so he and my mother jumped on a tour bus
came all the way across country to
california and the two of them made best
friends isn't that great wow